JESSE NICHOLS:
Fellow Googlers, I
am the host moderator for today.
My name is Jesse Nichols.
And I will be spending about 30
or 45 minutes in conversation
with John Cleese,
after which we'll
follow up with some questions.
I just wanted to let
you know that questions
can be posted to
[? adorigo/askjohncleese. ?]
Or if you're in the
audience, obviously,
just make sure you queue
up and I'll kind of signal
five minutes or
so in advance when
we're going to
jump to questions.
And it might be a
little earlier than that
if that's the way
he wants to go.
But just to give you a heads up.
For those of you who got a
book, hold onto it tightly.
No more books will be
available after that,
at least not here for free.
[AUDIO OUT]
--schedule will permit
him to be around for signatures
and photographs afterwards.
And on that note, he
has politely asked
[AUDIO OUT]
All right, welcome YouTube.
I will not waste any of your
time giving introduction
to a man who needs
no introduction.
Please let's welcome to
the stage, John Cleese.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN CLEESE: This is
my badge of honor.
Daily Show.
I had so much fun on that.
Did you see it?
Some people did.
It was lovely.
The first thing Jon
Stewart asked me, he said,
why have they got
the photograph wrong?
Why don't they show the whole--
it was a wonderful start.
You know, I was able to
shout into the wings,
are they all like this?
It was just good fun.
What are we going to-- I
just want to do one thing.
Can you all hear me OK?
Yep?
That's great.
That's a good start.
JESSE NICHOLS: Well
actually, to kick this off,
I did read that you prefer
very friendly or very rude
questions.
And I was wondering,
why the hell would
you believe something
as stupid as that?
JOHN CLEESE: Well, because
the worst questions you get
are the ones from California.
And people get up and say,
oh, Mr. Cleese, well, you're
so wonderful.
I've been watching you
since I was three months old
and you're just wonderful and
you've transformed my life
and you-- I just--
can you tell us
how we could become as
wonderful as you-- well,
not as wonderful as you
but could you give us
a few tips on how to--
that kind of crap.
You know, whether
it-- if somebody
says why have you been
married so many times,
it's immediately
interesting, you see?
That's why I say just ask
slightly rude questions.
It's much more fun.
JESSE NICHOLS: OK, well on
that note-- So, anyway--
JOHN CLEESE: Do you trust him?
I don't trust him.
Do you know him well?
JESSE NICHOLS: None of
these people know me.
JOHN CLEESE: Nobody knows you.
It's Jesse, right?
JESSE NICHOLS: It is Jesse.
Do tell us about this book.
So anyway what prompted
you to write this?
JOHN CLEESE: Well, I'll
tell you what it was.
It was conversation
with Michael Caine.
I know Michael a little bit.
And we used to always
holiday together.
I don't mean together, but
we would be in Barbados
at the same time with
two of my other friends.
[STATIC, CLUNKING NOISE]
And uh, shall we do
something about that?
Or, shall we just let it go on?
Do we know what's causing it?
JESSE NICHOLS: Both of us
should remain absolutely still.
JOHN CLEESE: That's good.
It's funny how
seldom-- it's just
like people who want
photographs, you know?
They always come up to you.
They say, can we
have a photograph?
I say to them, you mean
to commemorate the fact
that we met four seconds ago?
And then they take a
photograph, except they
don't take a photograph because
they get someone else to take
the photograph who doesn't
know how to work the camera.
And then the first two or
three shots don't work.
Then the guy I'm being
photographed with
goes back and takes
[STATIC NOISE] the camera.
This is the home
of high technology.
[LAUGHS] The lights
will go out in a moment.
Where was I?
JESSE NICHOLS: Something
about photographs.
JOHN CLEESE: Oh
yes, photographs.
So it always goes
wrong, it always
goes wrong when people want
photographs or microphones
or something like that.
I love the idea of technology,
but my phrase used to be,
isn't it wonderful?
It's a shame none of it works.
That's because
that's my experience.
You know, someone who
likes science but was never
very interested in technology.
How did we get on to that?
JESSE NICHOLS:
Michael Caine was in--
JOHN CLEESE: Michael Caine.
Michael Caine.
[STATIC NOISE]
Michael Caine told
me that he just
finished his own
autobiography and he'd
had a wonderful time writing it.
And I said, why?
And he said, because you
reclaim parts of your life
that you'd completely
forgotten about.
Now for people of your
age, it's hard to believe.
But by the time you get to 70,
there's great chunks of things
that you've completely
forgotten about.
But because the
memory is associative,
as you start to remember
things and try to figure out
what happened in
what order, it all
begins to start coming back.
And that's really
very satisfying.
You remember parts that you'd
lost and then what happens
is, you begin to see certain
patterns in your life
emerging which you had
not been aware of before.
This is sort of a little bit
of a narrative here and there
and you'd never sense there
was a sort of cause and effect.
JESSE NICHOLS: Interesting
that you put it that way,
this kind of discovering
or piecing together.
You get the sense of that,
certainly in the first third
of the book where you go
into what I would be proud
if I could remember such
depth into your youth
and leading up to university.
So-
JOHN CLEESE: Yes, but
you-- what happens
is, you remember the things
that are meaningful to you
and you forget all the rest.
And when you meet friends
from 40 years ago,
you find they have
a very clear memory
indeed, of two
incidents involving you
that you have no
memory of at all.
But you have two very
clear memories of them,
which they can't remember.
And it's very strange.
It's very selective.
But it's all down to
what is meaningful,
that's what sticks in your mind.
JESSE NICHOLS: Well,
what I found compelling,
if you could really break the
book up into sections, right?
There is youth, leading
up through high school,
or what we call high
school, you call it college.
There is university and then
there is post-university.
University is brief, but
then there is post-university
leading up to Monty Python.
So why did you choose
that chunk of your life
to be the exposition
of your biography.
JOHN CLEESE: Well,
people have said to me
that they were
disappointed there
wasn't more about Python in it.
And I was a bit bothered
when people said that.
And I said to my publishers,
we misled people.
And they said, no, if you'd
been writing a book about Monty
Python, it would've been called
Monty Python by John Cleese.
But an autobiography,
people should realize,
is basically to do with the
early part of your life,
at least at the start of it.
And this is quite a lot pages.
I can't remember what, but
it's about 125,000 words,
which is long for
the average book.
And that really only got me
up to the beginning of Python.
Because there was a lot
of other stuff I'd done.
I mean, a lot of people
naturally here don't know,
but I did a radio show that
did over 100 shows called,
"I'm Sorry, I'll
Read That Again."
It wasn't very good,
but it was very popular.
Then I did a series
with two guys
called Ronnie Corbett and Ronnie
Barker, who became very, very
famous in England,
had their own shows.
They were knows as
The Two Ronnies.
And when Ronnie
Barker died, it really
was a day of sort
of national lament.
He was a wonderful
guy and very funny.
Then I worked with
Marty Feldman and spend
a lot of time with him.
I worked with David Frost and
did a lot of time with him.
So that I had a
lot of experiences
in and around show business.
I was actually in
a Broadway musical,
which is kind of funny, because
I am hopeless at singing.
When I was young, Mr.
Hickley threw me out
of singing classes, because I
was just literally hopeless.
And when I was in America,
in New York in '64,
I got invited-- my agent
rang me up and said,
you've been invited to
audition for a British show.
And I said, what is it?
And he said, it's a musical.
And I laughed out loud
because it was so absurd,
me auditioning for a musical.
But I went along.
It was "Half a Sixpence."
It was a fellow
called Tommy Steele,
who was a big star at the time.
And I read the
dialogue and made them
laugh because I was playing
an upper class twit.
And then they said to me,
will you sing something?
And I said, no.
And they said, but it doesn't
matter what, just sing.
And I said, I can't
remember a tune.
And they said, well, could
you sing your national anthem?
I said, certainly,
how does it go?
And then I sang appallingly.
And two days later, I
went off, I was at home
and the phone rang and
they'd offered me the part.
And I said to my agent,
I can't, I can't sing.
And he said, well, he won't
notice just because you're only
in the chorus numbers.
And the moment I
went into rehearsal,
I went up to the
little guy who is
the musical director,
Stanley Lebowsky, and I said,
Stanley, I'm John Cleese.
I have to tell you.
I said at the auditions,
I cannot sing.
And Stanley, I
remember, he said, John,
I've been on Broadway 40 years.
Everybody can sing.
So he took me over to the
piano and 10 minutes later, he
changed his mind.
He just told me
to mime the words.
And that's what I used to do.
I used to go out there and mime.
One day after about six weeks,
I joined in very quietly one day
in the chorus numbers.
And Stanley was waiting
for me in my dressing room.
When I came out, he said,
John, are you singing?
That's the first
time anyone's ever
said that to someone
in a musical.
So I have all sorts of
odd experiences like that.
And I also taught for two years,
which I thoroughly enjoyed,
really enjoyed that.
So all of that's in there.
But a lot of it is about
tracing the development
of a sense of humor.
Because even when
I was 14, I mean
there was never in my
mind, even the possibility
the I would become a
professional comedian.
I mean, in the place
that I grew up,
a little sleepy,
seaside resort, I
was as likely to become
a matador or the Pope
as a comedian.
I mean, it just simply
wasn't on our radar screen.
And when I got to
Cambridge, I happened
to join a club called
The Footlights, which
is like the crazy, the Hasty
Pudding Club at Harvard.
And I joined it just
for fun, because I
liked the people in it.
And what happened after
that was that I started
to get into the end of
academic year shows.
And when I did the last one
of those in my third year,
because at Cambridge,
you only do three years,
suddenly the show was very,
very good, not because of me.
I was not the star of the show.
There were two other guys called
Tim Brooke-Taylor and Bill
Oddie and they were
the stars of the show.
And an impresario put us in
the West End for five months.
This little student review
ran in the West End, you know,
which is London's
Broadway, for five months.
And the BBC came along,
BBC radio offered me
a job was as a writer-producer
and I was a performer.
And so I thought, well, I
don't want to be a lawyer.
I never wanted to be a lawyer.
And so, I escaped and suddenly
found myself in show business.
And the great thing was, because
the BBC had offered me a job,
my parents were OK about it.
Because the BBC was
like the Civil Service.
And I was able to say, yes,
I've joined the pension scheme.
JESSE NICHOLS: It's
interesting that you put it
in the context of
a narrative though.
I definitely got the sense
of that as I read the book.
And I've got plenty of
friendly questions in here,
but a rather rude one.
JOHN CLEESE: Do it.
JESSE NICHOLS: The first third
of your book, I was wondering,
will this all be an aside,
as you were growing up,
you didn't realise, you didn't
at least admit to showing
of a ton of comedic talents.
It's not like you were the
class clown or constantly
playing pranks.
And I'm saying, where did the
John Cleese that come from?
And you get to a point where
the next thing you know,
you're on your London's
Broadway, you're on the BBC,
and I actually didn't like that.
Because you're giving too
much leeway to 23-year-olds
who took two years
before graduating college
and don't know
where they're going
and say, don't
worry, Mom, by 30,
I'll be the next Monty Python.
JOHN CLEESE: Well, yes, I mean
there were a couple of things.
When I first went to
my prep school, which
is sort of eight to
13, I didn't mix in
very well, because
my parents had
moved some insane
number times, like 11
times in 12 years or
something like that.
So I was never in
one place and I never
had time to form any strong
friendships with other boys.
So that was a difficulty.
And also I was an only
child of older parents.
Dad was 46 when I was born.
Mother was 40, which is
really quite old in 1939.
So I had not really
been socialized.
I'd just sort of been
very happy on my own,
playing games on my own, and
according to Sammy Davis,
becoming creative.
Because Sammy Davis always
said that being on your own
and being bored was
a wonderful source
of creativity, which
it may well be.
So when I arrived
in school, I just
didn't fit in terribly well.
People didn't like me much.
But I think I soon discovered
that if I could make them
laugh, there was a
feeling of warmth.
You'll all know what it's like
to tell a story successfully
at a dinner party or
at a cocktail party.
You know, you feel good.
You feel the warmth.
And I think
unconsciously, that' what
took me towards
making jokes in class.
But I wasn't the class clown.
You're quite right.
I was much-- I had a sort
of sneakier version of it.
In fact, it was a master
called Mr. Whitmarsh
who taught me history.
And Mr. Whitmarsh, I'll
tell you in a second,
absolutely summed me up.
But I have to tell you,
he amused me a lot,
because he couldn't pronounce
his own name properly.
And that's quite unusual.
He couldn't say he
was Mr. Whitmarsh.
He said his name was Mr.
W-w-whitmarsh And he'd
chosen to teach history
of the 17th century,
so you had to teach all
about the R-r-reformation
and the Counter R-r-reformation
and the R-r-roundheads
and the L-l-loyalists and Oliver
C-c-cromwell and [INAUDIBLE]
and Prince R-r-rupert of the
R-r-rhine the R-r-restoration.
If he'd taught 18th
century history,
he would just have to get
through the R-r-regency
and all would have
been plain sailing.
And it fascinated me.
We would ask him questions to
see how many Rs we could get.
But the point of telling you
is that he wrote in my history
report once, he
said, Cleese indulges
in subversive activities
at the back of the room.
That was the entire
history report.
So there was a bit of
me that liked laughing.
But it wasn't a very bold,
in your face kind of stuff.
It was sly.
JESSE NICHOLS:
Well, it certainly
seems to be a recurring
theme, exploring
where your sense of creativity
and humor, if not personal,
something maybe more general,
where that comes from.
So what were some of your
big conclusions from this?
JOHN CLEESE: Well, the
first thing I noticed
is that I did-- I got into
science-- into Cambridge
on science, on physics.
And I realized when I arrived
at Cambridge, to my horror,
that there were people doing
physics who were actually
interested in it.
So I thought, well,
what else can I do?
And there were very
few other things
that I was qualified to do.
But one was the law.
And so I said, all
right, I'll do that.
Because I've always used
words fairly precisely.
And legal thinking
is very simple.
It's just a question
of does this case
fall into this category
or that category.
And if you can
categorize accurately,
then law becomes easy,
at least intellectually.
I think when you get in
the real practice of law,
it's all about rather
dishonest tactics and sort
of maneuvering the other
side and never accepting
the 1% of the blame or anything.
I don't like that
side of law at all.
But intellectually,
it was interesting.
How did I get on to that?
JESSE NICHOLS: How you
developed, certainly such a--
JOHN CLEESE: Oh that's right.
Sorry.
Well, when I got to Cambridge
and I joined The Footlights,
partly by accident,
just because the guy
I was sharing digs
with knew someone
who was already
in The Footlights.
So it was a sort of inside job.
I got in there and I
started to discover
that I could write on a
piece of paper, words,
that if performed properly,
would make people laugh.
And no one had ever suggested,
in my first 21 years,
that I had a shred
of creative talent.
I mean, I wrote one or
two quite good essays.
We had to write
an essay on time.
And I wrote the
whole essay about how
I didn't have enough
time to write the essay.
And I thought that
was quite clever.
But you see, you're dealing
at Clifton College, my school
from 13 to 18, you're
dealing with teachers
who are intelligent, but who
have no creativity at all.
So they can't recognize it.
Do you see what I mean?
So when I discovered
I could write
stuff that made people laugh,
it was an astonishing discovery
to me.
And the first thing
I found, which
is the key to everything--
because I actually
lecture on creativity.
--the thing I
discovered immediately
was that if I was working on
something fairly late at night,
and I might work on it for an
hour, 45 minutes or something
like that, and then
I would go to sleep.
Come on in.
It's fine.
You're all right?
You're welcome.
I would work on it
quite hard and then
I would sit down, and have a
cup of chocolate, and go to bed.
And when I woke up the morning,
I'd make myself a cup of coffee
and go over to the desk,
and within two or three
minutes I had the
solution to what I'd
been blocked on
the previous night.
And I began to find
this very strange
because it happened
all the time.
And I suddenly realized
it must-- could only
be that my mind, my unconscious,
was working on the problem
while I was asleep.
And I began to learn the basic
principle of creativity, which
is that it comes
from the unconscious.
And if you think that's
an odd thing to say,
did you know that when Edison
was trying to have an idea--
you know this.
Somebody's nodding.
He used to keep a
metal bowl on the floor
and he used to have ball
bearings in his hand.
Because he felt that his best
ideas came in that sort of
hinterland between being
asleep and still being awake.
And he had the ball bearings
because when he fell asleep,
he would drop the
ball bearings and they
would drop into the metal
pan and wake him up again.
And that would
enable him to stay
in this sort of
semi-dream world, where
he thought he got
most of his ideas.
And the guy who
understood, finally,
the structure of the carbon
atom, whose name was something
von Stradonitz, Kekule von
Stradonitz or something,
he suddenly understood it
because he was very tired one
night and he was
looking into a fire.
And as he saw the flames
flickering, you know,
he sort of fantasized
that they were
snakes trying to
bite their own tails.
And the more he
thought about that,
the more he suddenly realized
it was a carbon ring.
So that's a good
example that you
don't get the stuff of the
unconscious printed out
in a nice piece of paper.
You get just odd intimations.
Einstein himself said
that muscular feelings
were a part of his
creative process.
So it's important to realize
that creativity doesn't
come from the left
brain, you know,
the logical, linguistic,
mathematical part.
It doesn't come from that.
You can make very small advances
with that side of the brain.
But anything that's a really
new and unusual breakthrough
kind of revelation,
that will always
come from the right brain.
That will always come
from the unconscious.
And I don't mean the Freudian
unconscious with this dustbin
that we put our most aggressive
and unpleasant feelings into.
I'm talking about
the unconscious that
enables you to drive
to the office every day
without really thinking
what you're doing.
If you try to think what you're
doing when you tie shoelaces
together, it gets in the way.
There's certain things that
your unconscious mind does
extraordinarily
well for you and you
don't have to bother
with them, like you
guys on your computers or
people who play the piano.
And so there's a lot of very
intelligent stuff going on
in the unconscious
and the question
is how to get in touch with it.
And I think that the only
ways you get in touch with it
is by creating what I call
an oasis, a quiet place.
So you have to have boundaries
of space and boundaries
of time.
Because the two
things that fuck up
creativity are
interruptions and anxiety.
And the greatest research
that was ever done,
was done on some architects.
A guy who used to
teach at Berkeley,
I forgot his name,
a Scottish name.
He interviewed
all the architects
who were picked
out by their peers
as the greatest architects,
the most creative ones.
And he asked them
literally, what
they did from the moment
they got up in the morning
to the moment they
went to bed at night.
And then he went all
the other architects
who weren't very creative,
though he didn't tell them
that was why.
And asked them what they did
from the moment they got up
in the morning until the moment
they went to bed at night.
And what he discovered was
there were two differences
between the creative ones
and the uncreative ones.
Nothing to do with IQ,
completely unrelated.
The first was that the creative
architects knew how to play,
how to play with an idea.
And that means to get really
absorbed and interested in it.
And he called it childlike.
Because you know how
children, when they really
get interested in
something, how utterly
absorbed they become,
without any sense of time,
thinking, now if I pull
it's wing off, what happens?
You know, now if I
pull this leg off,
and they're in a
world of their own.
The architects were like that.
And the other thing that might
interest and surprise you
is that they deferred decisions
as long as they could.
If a decision had to be
taken at a certain time,
then they took it.
But they didn't take it
before it had to be taken.
And those were the
characteristics
of creative people, which is
very different from what you're
basically taught at school.
I think.
And I'm entirely
sure it's right.
Because I keep reading
books on creativity.
And that's all they
ever regurgitate.
Nobody's really
discovered anything new
about creativity
since about 1980
because it's just
about knowing how
to get in touch with
the unconscious.
And once you've
said that, there's
not much you can say about
it, because the rest of it
is unconscious, so how
can you write about it?
Does that makes some sense?
JESSE NICHOLS: There were a
number of nuggets, actually
of wisdoms that you pulled
out throughout the book.
And some of them were
about creativity.
Some of them were just
about kind of human nature.
At one point, you talk
about Cleese's two rules
of comedy which kind of struck
a chord with what you were just
saying.
Do you remember--
JOHN CLEESE: I don't
even remember--
I haven't read the bloody thing.
I just wrote it.
JESSE NICHOLS: Just one
draft, send to print.
JOHN CLEESE: Well,
yes, that's right.
If I was happy with a page,
I just handed it over.
And I think there's a point,
provided you're happy with it
at one stage, if you
keep looking at it,
you'll always want to
change it a little bit
and you're not necessarily
making it any better.
And I trusted my editor.
If my editor thought
something wasn't right,
he'd point it out to me
and I would rewrite it.
But I don't know
what those-- I used
to have three rules of comedy.
And those were very simple.
That was, no puns was rule one.
Rule two was absolutely no puns.
And rule three was
no puns whatsoever,
under any circumstances.
Those were my three main rules.
Do you remember what--
JESSE NICHOLS: One of them
was to kill the anxiety.
And to do that through practice.
So a lot of what
you were teaching
through going back and reviewing
what made you the comedic
and writing talent that
you became was process.
JOHN CLEESE: Yes.
I was very, very
interested in process,
in a way that most of my
friends weren't I have to say.
They seemed to think that if
you understood the process too
well, that might
reduce your creativity.
And I think that's nonsense.
I've had an immense
amount of therapy.
I had an extraordinarily
difficult relationship
with my mother.
We finished up
fond of each other
because we had time to repair
the relationship, to make
reparation as the
psychiatrists say,
because she lived
to 101, not bad, ay?
But it was something that put
me into therapy a great deal.
Because I was finding it very
hard to get relationships
with women right.
Most of the rest of my
life worked pretty OK.
I mean, I made the
usual quota of mistakes
that everybody does.
But you know what I mean, by
and large, the rest of the life
was all right.
But the stuff with females
was very hard for me.
Because I went through
this single sex school
from eight to 18.
I mean, all you ever saw was
the maids who served food up
at lunchtime and the
headmaster's wife.
And that was pretty much it.
So if you have a
very odd mother--
and she was pretty crazy.
I mean, she was just sort of--
I used to say that she
suffered from omniphobia.
You name it, she had
a morbid dread of it.
And she was terrified
of almost everything.
And she needed her
own way all the time.
And if she didn't get her own
way, she would have tantrums.
And Dad, who'd been
rather a brave soldier
in the first World War, he was
quite frightened of Mother.
I think there were times when
he would rather have been back
in the trenches of France.
He would have found it a
more tranquil experience.
But because she was
very touchy, and we
live treading on eggshells
and all that stuff,
I had to spend an awful
lot of time in therapy.
And people said, but if
you understand the process
too much, you'll
become less creative.
I don't think that's true.
I think what happens is
you become less driven,
which means that you may
not be so productive.
But I think it
actually frees you up
to become more
creative because you
can go to parts of your
mind that otherwise you
would have backed
away from because they
made you uncomfortable.
Does that make sense?
I have an instinct
at this moment.
Does anyone have a
question about any of this?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN CLEESE: Oh
yes, that's right.
If you can go up to the mic.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN CLEESE: Yes, yes, I do.
Because you see, what
you're going to say
is that if you know how
to use the unconscious,
you will be creative.
You'll have good ideas, but
you won't necessarily-- sorry.
You'll have ideas, but they
won't necessarily be good ones.
I mean, just because you have
an idea, doesn't mean it's good.
So then you've got to bring
in what I would call the more
critical, left brain part, to
assess the idea after a time.
Because after you've
assessed it, it doesn't mean
it's suddenly a wonderful idea.
There may be a bit of it
that you think is very good
and other bits that
aren't so good.
So then you can go back into
the creative phase again.
Do you see what I mean?
And start becoming creative.
And then often you
feel a bit overloaded
when you've had too many ideas.
And that's the
moment when you've
got to start nailing them
down and examining them
with the left brain.
So that you can have a process
of iteration, by which you
constantly have new ideas
and then you reassess them.
And when you've
think you figured out
what's good and works
and what doesn't work,
then you can start working
again on the same stuff
and just keep going
round and round.
And I think that's what happens.
I think you reach a conclusion--
you know Karl Poppers work?
The philosopher of
science, you know,
who said that really, you
never know what the truth is.
All you know is that
the latest theory
is the one that seems to
solve most of the problems.
But you never really
know what it is.
And I think that's what happens.
You take it so far
and then you suddenly,
suddenly spot something else.
And then you integrate
that, and then
you suddenly spot
something else.
That's certainly been my
experience a lot of the time.
Because, particularly
with audiences,
I'm constantly
learning from audiences
because they tell
you what works.
And that my big surprise--
you see, in the old days,
if I went out in the theater in
front of an audience, I would,
if I wasn't doing so well, I
would think it was my fault.
I would think, oh, my
timing's off tonight.
And then, of course, I'd worry
and I would tighten up inside
and when you tighten up, then
your timing isn't quite good.
Anyone who plays sports
knows that that's the case.
But in fact, when I went into
movies, you'd make the movie
and you'd cut the movie
and put it up on the stage
and you'd watch the
audience and they
would respond quite differently
on different nights.
And it's exactly the same film.
You see what I mean?
And when I do my one man show,
I show little clips from things,
like the Black Knight sketch.
And I sit and I watch
the first three rows
because the light
from the screen
enables me to see the faces
in the first three rows.
And they're all laughing
at different times.
They're all laughing
at different things.
And I think it's because
when we sit in an audience,
laughter is infectious.
And we tend to infect
each other and sort of
think we're all laughing
at the same thing.
but when you get people
sitting in at home,
particularly reading
a book, you get
a completely different reaction.
I mean, "The Wall Street
Journal" gave this
a dreadful review.
Did you know about that?
I mean, they liked Dick
Cheney's autobiography.
But they gave it
a dreadful book.
And the people who've
been interviewing me,
who've on the whole, I have
to say American journalists,
television, radio, print,
are so much more professional
than the British ones
who don't read the book.
They've read the book.
And they basically think it's
amusing and fun and quite
interesting.
And when they saw
this Wall Street,
they'll all
commented, they said,
this isn't the book we read.
But the answer is, it is.
But people's judgment
and their sense humor
is very much more
subjective than we think.
JESSE NICHOLS: It's
those kinds of lessons
that you extracted
that I think make
this such a must read for
aspiring comedic writers,
aspiring comedians in general.
There was a point
in my life where
I dabbled in stand up comedy
just to build my own confidence
and interest in the subject
and just to see what--
JOHN CLEESE: How long did-- You
mean, you performed stand up?
JESSE NICHOLS: I did
stand up for at least
once a week for an entire year.
JOHN CLEESE: Really?
JESSE NICHOLS: So, 60 or
70, yeah, so about 60 or 70
performances.
JOHN CLEESE: So what did I say
in the book that surprised you?
JESSE NICHOLS: One of them
was-- it would have just
been nice to know this
before going into it,
was this notion that
comedy is so personal.
You have a sense
of this, but you
know that when there's
a crowd of people,
they tend to laugh together.
But you don't have a
sense of how different
the responses to the
same material will be
and how you can't
let that destroy you.
You can't let one
night destroy you.
It really should be a
trend that destroys you.
JOHN CLEESE: That's
exactly right.
That' extremely well put.
That's absolutely right.
If nobody ever laughs at
you, yes, maybe you're
in the wrong business.
But there's no
question, you can go out
and you could have one audience
rolling around with stuff,
and then the next night,
you have an audience,
they're perfectly nice and
they don't laugh 1/3 as much.
By and large, if you're
in big urban areas,
the audiences are quicker
and they laugh for longer.
And if you go out into the
rural areas, then sometimes
it's awfully hard work.
Because they kind of-- you
have to prise the laughs out
of them.
You know what I mean?
You have to put extra energy in
and underline the jokes a bit
and just make it all
a little bit simpler.
And they don't even
laugh very much then.
And then at the end
of the show, you
get this extraordinary
reception.
And you think, well they
enjoyed it in their own way.
I tell you, the
funniest audience
I've ever-- well, there were
two audiences I played to.
When we first went to London,
this little student review,
they put this into a little
theater of 350 people.
And they gave us two
trial performances
because you need to
try comedy and you also
need to get to know the
feeling of each theater
because if you do it
slightly differently.
I mean the hardest presentation
I've done with the book
was in a room that was
very long and narrow.
And the microphones
weren't very good.
Well, that's-- you're
immediately screwed when that
happens, you know?
But anyway, we did
the first night,
we did a sort of dress rehearsal
performance to an audience.
And we'd done it in
Cambridge for two weeks
and in Oxford for a week.
So we had a pretty good idea
of what worked and what didn't.
And this audience
was the weirdest
I've ever met in my life,
because they laughed
at the lead up lines, and
then were completely silent
when we did the punchlines.
And it was utterly disorienting.
It was the worst
warm up audience
we could possibly have had.
And afterwards, I went to
the manager of the theater
and said, can you
explain this to me?
And he said, oh yes, there's
a convention in town.
They bought every
seat in the theater.
And I said, a
convention of what?
Oh, they're all psychiatrists.
And that was the single
weirdest audience.
The other one was in New
Zealand at a matinee,
when, before we went
onstage about two o'clock
in the afternoon,
there was a noise
that we've never hear before.
And we thought what is it,
a sort of tinkling noise.
And it was quite loud, well
not loud, but it was pervasive.
And somebody peeped
through the curtain
and we realized that the
audience consisting entirely
of 70-year-old ladies,
each one of whom
had a coffee cup or a
teacup, sorry, teacup.
And each one of whom
had Parkinson's disease.
So the noise coming
from these things
was absolutely deafening.
And when we went
out to do the show,
we started to do the
show as we always did,
and we got absolutely nothing.
There was no laughter at all.
We had a lot of jokes.
They didn't get any of them.
But they sat there
quite happily,
thinking what nice young men
and how well they've shaved,
and their hair is
the right length,
and they clearly all washed
before they came on stage.
And I was fascinated.
I had a very good piece called
the Old Testament weather
forecast, when I forecast
the plagues, as a weather
forecaster would.
You see, what I mean?
I said, well, on
Tuesday, there'll
be boils, and then death of
the firstborn, rivers of blood,
and my reign on the beast
and all this kind of thing.
And I always got
a huge laugh when
I said moving in from the
south, southeast, boils.
I always got a huge laugh.
So playing to complete
silence, there
was a thing going on
between all the performers.
I said, I'm going to get the
first laugh of this afternoon.
I'm going to get it on boils.
And we started betting money.
People were betting $10 that
I wouldn't get the laugh
and I was spending
$10 that I would.
And when I finally got out
up in front of the audience,
and I said-- did this whole
thing about rivers of blood,
death of the
firstborn, and said,
and now, moving in from the
south, southeast, boils.
And I said it very
loudly so that it
would penetrate their
hearing aids, nothing.
Except screams of
laughter from the wings.
I'm standing in front of
this audience, I lost it.
I just stood there crying
with laughter on my own,
howling, howling with laughter.
And they just sat
there watching me.
JESSE NICHOLS: Even in an early
comedy experience like that,
I can just hear the skit.
I can imagine it in the way that
you would probably deliver it.
And that's where the Python
I think resides in this book,
is in the moments and the skits
that churned and evolved over
the years, and became some
of your most iconic work,
and were probably hilarious
back then, but by the time
they were polished,
were really incredible.
A lesson for comedians?
JOHN CLEESE: But I'll tell
you something very odd.
That sometimes the
things that became iconic
were not received on
the first occasion
with any particular enthusiasm.
If you listen to the
very original tape
of the parrot sketch
or of the silly walks,
there's a bit of laughter.
It's not like Dunedin
and the coffee cups,
but it's extraordinary, it's
just very ordinary laughter.
And then you start thinking,
but so how did it become iconic?
And I think it
became iconic when
we start to do the stage shows.
But after all, if you do a
stage show in Southampton,
nobody knows about it,
other than the people
in South Hampton.
So I literally do not understand
how some of these sketches
just took off and became
part of the language.
And if you look at an
English newspaper now,
I would say that in a
week, there will be,
in any newspaper, there'll
be a reference to what
have the Romans ever done for
us, or this parrot is dead,
or something like that.
It's extraordinary how it
passes into the language,
because you just don't
see how it happens.
JESSE NICHOLS:
Lupins, or God knows.
JOHN CLEESE: Lupins.
Yeah, I love lupins.
JESSE NICHOLS: We'll
will be opening up
for questions in just
a couple of minutes.
I guess one of the things
that hadn't come up yet
that I thought was
particularly interesting
was the show where
you could tell
you were on the verge of
Python really coming together.
And that was the "1948
Show," timely because it also
ran into 1949.
JOHN CLEESE: Yeah, that's right.
Well, there was a show
that we started to do,
after David Frost picked me
out of obscurity in 1966,
to do a sort of
a satirical show,
but with not sort of
political sound, not
political satire,
more social satire.
And I did that and I did quite
a lot of shows at that time.
And David knew that
I wanted to try
a slightly wilder, crazier
zanier, more mad cap,
off the wall, out of
left field, type comedy.
And he asked me if I wanted
to do a show, and I said yes.
And I wanted to do it
with Marty Feldman, who
I knew very well because
he'd been the script
editor on the previous
show I'd done with David.
And he wasn't a
performer at all.
And David, you know Marty
Feldman a little bit?
Well, David was amazed,
and he said, well,
Marty's not to a performer.
And I said, he's
going to be wonderful.
I tell you, David.
And of course, he was.
And then Chapman was
on that, Graham Chapman
and Tim Brooke-Taylor.
And we did these 13 shows.
And they were very fresh,
they were very different.
And I always used to say it
was half a step towards Monty
Python.
And then, you won't believe
this, they wiped the shows.
Because this was in the
day when videotapes--
I have to use both hands but
they were that big and that big
and about that wide.
So if you had 13
of them, it started
to take up a lot of space,
and they began to wipe shows.
They wiped shows with
Chapman, me, and Feldman.
And now we're beginning
to discover them,
because they found five
compilation shows in a vault
in Swedish television and when
Marty's window, Loretta, died
last year, she left
me a couple of tapes
that were in her attic.
Nobody knew about them.
And then David Frost's second
son, Wilfred, who's my godson,
found two more.
And the one you're
talking about,
which was the last one we ever
did, we did 13 altogether.
It's so like a Monty Python
that if I showed it to you now,
apart from the different
faces doing the performance,
you'd think it
was a Python show.
And I had no idea that it
was so similar to Python.
I had no idea.
I'd forgotten just
how similar it was.
So this is part of the
story in the book about how
we got to Monty Python.
JESSE NICHOLS: No, it
was really well played
and you could, just again,
you could hear the voices.
That was your first time
seriously collaborating
with Graham.
Or it sounded like
it was at least
the first extensive period
you spent working with him
and it also teed up
the relationships
you made with Terry,
I guess, the Terrys.
JOHN CLEESE: I tell you what,
have you got a book there?
Turn to 295 and we'll
do one of the sketches
because this is example of
the-- this is an example.
Excuse me.
So I hate these.
[STATIC SOUND]
Blech, blech.
295.
Here we are.
You come into my
office because you
want to take a memory
training course.
OK?
JESSE NICHOLS: Go with
the British accent,
just to stay in character.
JOHN CLEESE: You want to?
All right.
OK.
So I'm the guy sitting at the
desk and I say to you, come in.
Good morning.
Come in.
Thank you.
Do sit down.
Now what can I do for you?
JESSE NICHOLS: Well, I'm
interested in your memory
training program.
JOHN CLEESE: Good,
well a lot of people
feel they'd like to
improve their memories.
The wonderful thing
is, improving them
is not as hard as um, as
hard as um, as hard as nails.
JESSE NICHOLS: I
beg your pardon?
JOHN CLEESE: As hard as nails.
It's word association.
You see, it's the
basis of my system.
You remember things by
associating with uh,
with uh, people like that.
JESSE NICHOLS: People like what?
JOHN CLEESE: They like
to improve their memory.
You see?
Now, what can I do for you?
JOHN CLEESE: Well, I'm
interested in your course.
Good.
You remembered that.
You see, you have learned
to associate your interest
in my course with
my asking you why.
Association of ideas,
the basis of everything
we do to acquire
a better memory.
But it's not as hard as um--
JESSE NICHOLS: I think--
JOHN CLEESE: No,
as hard as nails.
Remember?
Never mind.
You'll soon pick it up.
Now take a common
object like this.
JESSE NICHOLS: A saucer.
JOHN CLEESE: A saucer.
Good.
Well done.
Now, what does it
make you think of?
JESSE NICHOLS: Well, uh--
JOHN CLEESE: What
would you, what
would you like to think of?
JESSE NICHOLS: Like to think of?
JOHN CLEESE: A nude woman.
JESSE NICHOLS: A nude woman?
Well done.
You're getting it.
Now, what is the
nude woman doing?
JESSE NICHOLS: Drinking tea?
JOHN CLEESE: Good.
And what's she
drinking tea out of?
JESSE NICHOLS: A cup?
JOHN CLEESE: Quite right.
A cup and-- saucer.
You see?
Are you getting it?
JESSE NICHOLS: I'm not sure--
JOHN CLEESE: Well, one
of the association idea
is that the basis of our
method, indeed the whole,
the whole in the wall.
And what do I see through
the hole in the wall?
A nude woman.
Do you see?
Every time, every time, every
time, yes, yes, it's good.
Of course, it's such a
strong image, you see?
You can't forget it.
You associate that with anything
that you want to remember.
Anything at all, numbers,
dates, names, anything.
Try, try, try again.
JESSE NICHOLS:
Battle of Trafalgar.
JOHN CLEESE: Ah, Trafalgar.
Trafalgar, Trafalgar Square,
square, hole in the wall,
look through the square
hole in the wall.
What do I see?
JESSE NICHOLS: A nude woman?
JOHN CLEESE: Excellent.
Excellent.
And who is this nude woman?
JESSE NICHOLS: I don't know.
JOHN CLEESE: The
Empress Josephine.
1815.
See it rhymes, Josephine, 15.
JESSE NICHOLS:
1815 was Waterloo.
Trafalgar was 1805.
JOHN CLEESE: Now, wait a minute.
I haven't finished.
Uh, Josephine's wearing
boots, Wellington boots.
You can't see her toes.
So deduct 10 from
the 1815, 1805.
Simple.
JESSE NICHOLS: Right.
the date of Waterloo.
JOHN CLEESE: Uh, well, 1815.
JESSE NICHOLS: But
how do you do it?
JOHN CLEESE: Ah, wait a moment.
Ah, Waterloo, Waterloo Station,
Waterloo Station, trains,
train to Brighton,
Brighton Pier,
peer through the
hole in the wall,
and there's the Empress
Josephine in the nude, 1815.
JESSE NICHOLS: But she
has Wellington boots on.
JOHN CLEESE: No,
Battle of Waterloo.
Duke of Wellington.
In he comes.
Wants his boots back,
so he sees her toes,
no need to deduct ten.
Waterloo 1815.
See?
JESSE NICHOLS: Fire of London.
JOHN CLEESE: What?
The date of the fire of London.
JOHN CLEESE: Oh, well,
let me see, let me think.
Date of the Fire of London.
Fire, fiery, diary, diary,
Samuel Pepys, Samuel Pepys
had a diary, yes, he wrote
about the Fire of London.
Ah, Samuel Pepys.
Samuel Pepys, peeps through
the whole in the wall.
And what does he see?
JESSE NICHOLS: A nude woman?
JOHN CLEESE: No, three
nude women, you see?
By the light of the fire,
he sees three stunning,
gorgeous, nude
women, sex, sex, sex.
Sexteen sexty sex.
If you'd seen that
sketch in Monte Python,
it wouldn't have been out
of place at all, would it?
It's fascinating.
So I had no idea until I started
going back a long time to 1967,
I had no idea how much of
Monty Python was, as it were,
encapsulated it
in the 1948 show.
JESSE NICHOLS:
Absolutely incredible.
We have time for a
few more questions.
I want to make sure the
audience gets a chance here.
JOHN CLEESE: Good.
Excellent.
AUDIENCE: I just had
a quick question.
JOHN CLEESE: A little
closer to the mic, I think.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
I heard someone say
somewhere that all humor is
subversive at the heart of it.
You mentioned that you as
a child were subversive.
And I just wanted to
get your take on that.
JOHN CLEESE: Yes I
think, I'll tell you
why I think--
there's two reasons.
The first one is
that people who are
very pompous and
authoritarian, they
have organizations, which stamp
out any kind of criticism.
You know, people
are terrified to say
what they think because
if they really disagree
with the people in
charge, they're in trouble
and they may get fired.
Now in places like that, and it
was a bit like that in the USSR
not so long ago,
then the only way
that people could express
criticism or discontent
was through humor.
They could make jokes.
So the ones, the
people in charge,
saw jokes as subversive,
as subverting
the system, the
power system, which
gave them all their power.
So they kind of dismissed
humor as subversive.
And there's a certain kind
of very puritanical mind
that mistrusts humor.
There was a famous case
of somebody working
for Henry Ford in a factory
called the Red River Factory.
I don't know where Red River is.
But there was a guy there
who was fired for laughing.
And then there was
an inquiry about why.
He had been warned the
previous month for smiling.
So when you get people
who are absolutely
obsessional about doing
things, then any kind of humor
is a threat to that
obsessional pursuit of a goal.
You can imagine
that there were not
a lot of jokes going
around Himmler's SS.
Do you see what I mean?
But if you look at humor,
it's really about two things.
If you laugh at a
character in a comedy,
it's always because
he is not, he's
not behaving appropriately.
It's only inappropriate
behavior that could be funny.
Similarly, comedy is
about things going wrong.
If somebody goes
off on a journey,
and everything goes right,
there's nothing funny.
It starts getting funny
when things go wrong.
So that means that
people are funny when
they're inappropriate and things
are funny when they go wrong.
So there's
essentially something,
when we laugh that's critical.
You know.
We're laughing at someone
because they're not
behaving appropriately or
because they screwed up
and so things are going wrong.
You see what I mean?
So there's an element-- It is
true to say that all humor is,
in some very subtle
way, critical.
Because if you have somebody
whose life is going smoothly
and who is behaving
appropriately,
there's no way you
could make them funny.
But that's a little different
from the subversive attitude.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Is there
any dream project
that you haven't
had the chance to do
and what is one of the
biggest mistakes of your life?
JOHN CLEESE: Well, I think
trying to rema-- when
I did the "Fish
Called Wanda" sequel,
I shouldn't have
cast the same people.
Because it was an attempt
to do a quite different kind
of movie, and by
casting the same people,
people thought I was trying
to do the same kind of movie.
You know, I thought "A Fish
Called Wanda" was very funny,
but it's very sort of
cynical, hard-edged thing.
And I was trying to make a
movie that actually families
could go to and kids could
laugh at it with their parents.
So that was a mistake.
What was the first
thing you said?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN CLEESE: Yes, I would love
to do a series of documentaries
about what religion would be if
the churches hadn't fucked it
up.
I think that would be
really interesting.
JESSE NICHOLS: Wasn't that
called "The Meaning Life"?
JOHN CLEESE: No, no, no.
Because certainly
"Life of Brian."
JESSE NICHOLS: Oh,
Sorry.
JOHN CLEESE: Yeah,
certainly "Life of Brian"
But "Life of Brian" was a
joke, not about religion.
But about how people
follow religion,
so it was related to that.
But I think it's
very interesting
because when I read about
the mystical experience,
I do have a sense that
something is going on,
which is not entirely
explicable in terms
of the usual materialist
reduction, as scientists view.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Most of your writing
that I'm familiar with,
the sketch comedy
and movie scripts
and corporate videos
and things like that,
are a very different style of
writing than an autobiography.
I wondered if being so practiced
at that sort of writing
made it difficult to
write an autobiography
or if it kind of
made it easier just
because you're used to writing.
And from reading
the book, it doesn't
seem like it was-- it doesn't
read like it was hard for you
to write.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN CLEESE: It was not as hard
as I thought, whereas you see,
if I think-- I have
a feeling that if I'd
tried to write a novel, I
don't think I could do it.
I don't know why.
I just don't feel that my
skills would extend to that.
But because I've written
for television and film
all my life, it's natural
for me to write dialogue.
So I knew I'd be able
to write dialogue
but I didn't know if I'd
be able to write narrative.
And all I did was, whenever
I wrote a sentence,
I read it out as though
it was a line of dialogue,
even when it was narrative.
And I just found that if it
sounded right, I left it.
And if it didn't sound
right, and you guys in IT
will be delighted to know
that I wrote with a propelling
pencil in an exercise book.
And I loved the contact.
And I would just keep
on rubbing out that line
and writing it until it sounded
right when I read it out.
And my editor, who did
an extraordinary job,
he said, and I'd never
have guessed this,
he said the vast majority of
writers are fine on narrative
and can't do dialogue
to save their lives.
So I started the
other way round,
and found that actually
writing in the narrative
was not difficult.
But that was because I
just was listening to it.
And the nicest thing people
have said about the book
is that it's like having a
dinner conversation with me.
They can hear my voice.
So I was surprised to
find that, but pleased.
AUDIENCE: Right on.
Thank you.
JOHN CLEESE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yes, sir.
So we have a question
from the internet.
From Rick Elliott,
who notes that you
are rightfully famous
for your comedy.
Have you done serious
dramatic roles?
And if so, would you contrast
those with your humorous work?
JOHN CLEESE: Well, yes.
I did do one very dramatic role.
I'm going to read it to you.
Have I got-- oh, yeah.
Thank you.
I think this is quite funny.
This was the first
time I was ever
asked to do a straight role.
And it was a very strange
thing that happened.
Let me just come
to the right place.
Because it was my house,
my school, 13 to 18,
was divided into houses,
groups of about 70 or 80.
And there was the house play
competition every spring term.
And we decided to do "Faust."
Two of the boys were
interested in acting,
so they got the big parts,
Faustus and Mephistopheles.
I was given the smaller,
but crucial role of Lucifer,
the Prince Of Darkness,
the embodiment of evil,
the Antichrist himself.
Now I realized right
from the start,
that playing Satan
gave me a chance
to prove myself as a
serious, straight actor,
but I'm afraid it
was a devil too far.
Part of the problem
was my tights.
Somebody had decided
that in order
to make my first entrance
as terrifying as possible,
I should be dressed in
starkest black and tights.
Now, you know, because I've
related in the book earlier,
how unmuscular I was, right?
My legs were so thin, I
could have played a flamingo.
And yet, the director's
vision involved
putting me, of all
people, in black tights.
Now on the day of the
dress rehearsal studio,
I stood in pitch darkness
behind some black drapes,
waiting for the cue
for my entrance,
accompanied by a junior boy,
whose job it was to show me
where the gap in the drapes
was to be found through which
I could walk on to stage.
Then I heard my cue, the
boy parted the curtains
and I strode forward to
announce my first line which
was, (DEEP GRAVELLY
VOICE) I am Lucifer.
Before I had time
to open my mouth,
however, I was hit
by a wall of laughter
that shook the building.
It wasn't just the
tights, of course.
It was the idea that
this spindly twerp
could strike terror into
people's hearts, when
instead of frightening
the shift out of them,
he was more likely to cause
them to wet their pants.
Thinking quickly and realizing
the situation was lost,
I ad-libbed, (DEEP GRAVELLY
VOICE) I am ludicrous.
Another big laugh.
Now, later that evening--
that was the dress rehearsal.
During the actual performance,
things began to go downhill.
I took up my position
behind the black drapes.
And this time a different
boy was standing there
in the darkness.
I peered at him and
said, who are you?
He said, I'm Topman, Cleese.
Gould has a music lesson.
So I said, so you're
parting the drapes for me.
He said, what?
I said, you're parting
the drapes for me,
so that I can get on stage?
He said.
I don't know about that.
I said, What?
Well, what are you doing here?
He said, I don't know, Cleese.
He just asked me to
stand in for him.
So I could hear my cue coming
up in about 10 seconds.
I start groping the
drapes in the dark,
trying to find the gap
myself, desperately
grabbing at the
pitch black cloth,
in search of an opening
as the seconds tick away.
And there's my cue.
So I just walk forward
into the drapes
and keep trudging onward against
the weight of all the velvet
cloth that is clinging to me.
And the audience start
to giggle at the sight
of this strange, increasingly
large bulge in the back cloth,
that is ever more slowly making
its way towards-- The actors
step back in alarm.
At least I'm
frightening someone.
And I manage just
to keep moving,
so that when I have reached
a point about halfway
to the front of the stalls, the
drapes now at full extension,
start sliding back over my
head and finally fall away
from me, revealing a
strange creature, a lackard,
stick insect, apparently in
a fright wig, who announces,
(DEEP GRAVELLY
VOICE) I am Lucifer.
By which time most
of the audience
had lost contact
with their chairs.
That was my first attempt.
And then the next time I did it
was 34 years later for Kenneth
Branagh, when I was in
Mary Shelley's Frankenstein
and I played Kenneth Branagh's
anatomy tutor, Dr. Waldman,
and managed to play the
whole thing without getting
a single laugh, not even when
Robert De Niro stabbed me
to death.
So that was a considerable
accomplishment.
AUDIENCE: So you talked a lot
about the creative process,
which was really
interesting to hear,
because I haven't actually heard
you talk about that before.
What changes with that?
You talked a lot
about the unconscious
and how important
that is to creativity.
What changes when you're doing
something collaboratively
with somebody else?
JOHN CLEESE: Well,
first of all, you've
got to be very
relaxed with them.
When you start
writing with someone,
it's just a tiny little bit like
a sort of platonic first date.
Because you've got
get to know each other
and trust each other.
Do you see what I mean?
Because you have to,
to really be creative,
you have to say the first thing
that comes into your mind.
You mustn't process it
with the critical mind
before you voice it.
You've just got to say
what comes into your mind.
And that means you have to
have a certain amount of trust
in the person you're
with so he won't
think you're a complete prat.
Or she won't think you're
a complete prat if you
say something that is silly or
dumb or something like that.
So there's a
process in which you
have to get very, very
comfortable with someone.
Once you've done
that, what happens
is that the ideas
build off each other.
You sort of bat things
backwards and forwards.
And they move forward
so fast that you
can't see the
process at the time.
But all you do is, when you
do get to the good idea,
after batting it
backwards and forwards,
you can never really
remember how you got there.
Do you see what I mean?
Only it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
You literally don't
know who said what,
but you know that you've
got to this thing.
And it's because you've got two
minds batting off each other.
So you get somewhere
that I think
you wouldn't get on your own.
Now, obviously you can't do
that with an autobiography,
because it's so highly personal.
Now, if you're writing
a play, in which there's
some particular thing
you want to say,
well, you shouldn't write
that with somebody else
unless they have exactly
the same views as you.
Do you see what I mean?
You should just-- I think
that thing that sums it up.
You get to a place you'd
never get on our own.
That's the advantage of
collaborative writing.
But I have to say, you have
to keep the group very small.
If you try and get four people
writing creatively together,
you get nothing done at all.
Because always one of
the four will disagree.
When there's three, you could
get a certain amount done,
but it's a slower process.
So I think really
two is the best.
And what used to
happen in Python,
we worked in twos
and ones, and then we
would get together
every six or seven days
and read out what we'd written.
And then we would simply see
whether we laughed or not.
I mean it was very simple.
If we all thought it was
funny, we all laughed,
it was in the show.
And if not, we would send
it off to some other show.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
JOHN CLEESE: OK.
Yes.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: A few years
ago, I found myself
at the Globe Theatre in London.
And I was standing on
a paving stone that
said Michael Palin
spelled incorrectly.
And next to it was one with
your name, spelled correctly.
JOHN CLEESE: Say that,
one was Michael Palin
AUDIENCE: Pallen.
JOHN CLEESE: Palin,
you must say Palin.
He doesn't like
being called Pallen.
AUDIENCE: But it
was spelled Pallen.
JOHN CLEESE: Oh, that's right.
OK.
That's right.
Yes.
You're absolutely right.
Oh, my god.
You're way ahead of me.
That's right.
Michael doesn't like
being called Pallen.
So I paid-- I paid to have
one of those stones put
in with a double L.
Oh, the worst thing I ever did
was, at the Hampstead Theater,
when they were asking people who
went regularly, to put up money
to buy seats in
people's names, right?
And I bought one of the
name of Martin Bormann.
Now, he was part of Hitler's
very tight group of associates.
And nobody spotted it.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if Michael Palin knows
about that stone at the Globe.
And if you know, what
his reaction was?
JOHN CLEESE: You know,
I'm not absolutely sure.
I will ask him.
But I'll tell you
a story about Palin
because he and I played jokes
on each other all the time.
And on one occasion,
somebody came to me and said,
would you and Michael like
to do some program together?
And I thought that would be fun.
So I thought how do I
get hold of Michael?
So I called his home.
And Helen answered.
And of course, he was off making
one of those, [YAWN] sorry,
one of those travel
programs of his.
And Helen said, he's at
this hotel in Helsinki.
So I thought well, I'll give
him a call this evening when
he's finished shooting.
And I called him
and asked for him.
I said, can I speak
to Mr. Palin, please.
And there was the usual delay
while they put me through.
And while I was waiting,
I thought to myself,
he doesn't know who this is.
Then I thought, he
doesn't know where I am.
So when he answered
the phone, and said,
hello, I said, (IN A NORWEGIAN
ACCENT) Ah, Mr. Palin,
my name is Larsley Bristom,
I'm a television producer
with NRK television in Oslo.
And were wondering if you might
just do an interview with us.
And he said, I'm awfully sorry
because I'm going to bed now
and I'm off early
in the morning.
And I said, no, Mr. Palin,
not an interview tomorrow,
but an interview now.
He said, now?
I said, yes, I'm downstairs
in the lobby of your hotel
with a film crew.
And we have the chairs set
up and the lighting is ready.
Could you come down?
And he said, I'm
already in my pajamas.
And I said, Oh, the
Norwegians would
think that was
very witty, if you
do the interview in
your pajamas, Mr. Palin.
That would be really funny.
He started to get quite ratty,
which Michael very seldom does.
So I kept going.
I said, but it's so important
that we interview you.
And he said, well why
is it so important.
I said, because we're doing
it to tribute to the greatest
comedian in the world,
Mr. John Cleese.
And it's very important that
we speak to one of his helpers.
He began getting really cross.
And I said, Michael, it's me.
And I swear, he laughed
for two minutes.
I mean, he just--
We've finished.
JESSE NICHOLS: I think so.
I think that wraps it up.
JOHN CLEESE: Are you all happy?
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN CLEESE: Thank you.
Oh, incidentally,
any of you who've
been nice enough
to buy a book, I
will be very happy to
sign that, if you'd
like to bring it up to me now.
OK, I'll put your
name and my signature,
unless you want someone
else's like Michael's.
JESSE NICHOLS: Thank you
everyone, for joining.
And John Cleese.